because that's even your interracial but
surely there's a very odd tension we
thought we very rarely argue my
girlfriend and I but she with the only
times there's kind of tension is when
she will be asleep and she will have a
dream in which I've cheated on her with
just some imaginary made-up dream lady
and then she'll wake up in the morning
and be really angry not really tell me
what's happened and so I'll just I won't
have any sense of it on I'll just be
making breakfast oh how would you like
your eggs
I don't know how would Isabella like
hers it's just weird cause it'll just
happen and I will never quite tell I'll
just have to piece it together like we
were in Venice and I could sense it
happened again when we were taking
separate gondola rides so you're loaded
that's about 400 quids worth it to
basically fight like what my wife once
you get stuff off stuff ah she's gonna
kill me for tell you this now right I've
really gotten Rogie but sometimes she's
off stuff to get up or lap she stands up
she got out off me right and I go you
can't do that and stuff because I you
start breaking stuff but if you push up
off the path to get at the bathrobe
right so you know I was waiting for a
new table to delivered we had to run
them you know like to fold up tables got
some tables that kept on telling then
shout leave me alone then one day was
every dinner and she stood up we're not
that table when she went down spaghetti
bolognaise on her face and it was one of
the greatest moments by
[Applause]
that'll hopefully balance out the moment
when she sees this show but now because
Lister you're fairly recently managed
what not not a year yet is it javi yeah
just yeah last year yeah I think but our
amazing husband yeah June but it's funny
how quickly you know in a marriage it
becomes really about the small things
doesn't it and I've realized there's now
the dishwasher has become a bit of a war
zone that you suddenly it's it's the
really little things isn't it that cause
the most trouble and I've realized our
essential differences that I like to
stuff the dishwasher incredibly full
yeah but as much stuff in there as
possible and my husband prefers it very
cleanly and efficiently stacked very
carefully and I'm hoping that we're
going to be able to resolve some
pointless dishwasher conflict start with
Charlie on this one my dishwasher works
the most efficiently when it's
efficiently loaded you stuff it in there
full of and you're gonna end up
with dirty dishes at the end you gotta
clean again anyway nobody get more stuff
in it anyway that's the thing you don't
want
mommy would Marty say this Marty would
do them by hand
[Applause]
[Music]
you